ben needed you spell
up Best Ramen Black g I'm
Moeka I'm playing drums g I've been in since my brother
's
day
this click story with
me Pass play proof liquor
Highway
[Music]
nodus ratna Paris
tonbo pudding  Gram Men's App
Cover Win Pile Treaty
[Music]
Voodoo
Woo-Doo But Pude-
Doo
[Music]
Toba and the number is good It's
like I remembered the drum before I remembered it too
naturally
Really on youtube  I
was able to do it in a week just by showing a great drummer's video. My
mom came-I sang songs while playing,
and sometimes I sang music as a bass,
so it's usually
a song that my dad or mom wanted to do.  Or we sometimes compose, write,
compose, etc., so there are a lot
of things to do, so next time I did it with everyone Thin
[Music]
tai
Asai Minoru Playing g 4 me you
do this Ellen  It's
a good place to think of Ed Whiskey Abu,
without a mirror
. I'm not nervous about the beach, but I'm a little
nervous. The
practice is beautiful, so it's a little difficult,
but I'm still looking forward to the actual performance in two episodes
.
I want to meet various people, so
I think there is a great social study open. [Music] [Applause] Besides, I can
enjoy it, but if different people get well, it will be fun
.
[music]